un difícil arranque de año para Nicolás
Maduro se completa una semana de
protestas en toda Venezuela por parte de
miles de trabajadores de distintos
gremios exigiendo al gobierno Un aumento
de sus salarios pensiones y la mejora de
beneficios sociales
salario mínimo debe ser acorde con el
artículo 91 es decir la canasta básica
es decir
$2000 mensuales el salario mínimo
mensual se encuentra en 130 bolívares
que equivale a unos 7 dólares
aproximadamente y para cubrir la canasta
alimentaria se necesitarían más de 50
sueldos mínimos según el observatorio
Nacional de finanzas el 2022 terminó con
una inflación del
305.7% y el Bolívar se devalúa un 73% de
respecto al Dólar Venezuela llegó a su
peor momento en 2017 y desde entonces
viene anunciando mejoras en sus finanzas
en 2022 el Banco Central anunció que el
pib tuvo un crecimiento del
18.70%, pero la sombra
hiperinflacionaria Aún se mantiene
latente frente al descontento social el
chavismo ha implementado el carnet de la
patria una bonificación que intenta
compensar la precariedad de Los sueldos
aunque no ha sido suficiente
te va los mejores restaurantes tenemos
más de 300.000 compatriotas que han
regresado
de 300.000 venezolanos han regresado por
su cuenta desde el 2020 por las
supuestas mejoras en las condiciones de
vida y de la economía en el país
caribeño